dr. Sachin man dead car is a man on a
mission and he's crossing the city of
Pune to make a rare house call he's here
to treat Rajiv kid car who suffers from
a chronic skin condition called
psoriasis and the Rajee of his eager for
doctor Sachin to ease his suffering he's
more than a little unsettled because he
knows the cure in this doctor's bag is
one that's certain to get under his skin
leeches every year millions of Indians
choose not to visit their country's
modern medical clinics instead they seek
traditional healers like dr. Sachin who
use leeches as part of an ancient system
of medicine called Ayurveda it's
holistic approach to treating illness
includes dietary changes curative oils
massages and relaxation therapies and
leeches for dr. Sachin the results speak
for themselves
results but even here leeches are often
taboo if I see a leech I can't stand it
I won't even go near it
why would anyone voluntarily allow
himself to become a meal for a blood
sucking leech Rajiv is convinced this
leech will provide relief for his
psoriasis he's tried Western medicine
and it hasn't worked in certain cases
like Rajiv psoriasis dr. Sachin and his
wife dr. kirtan and NCAR believe a
patient's ailment stem from toxins or
impurities in the blood basically
desired by the concept not in modern
science
Ayurvedic insists that leeches naturally
remove toxic blood from the body we just
applied the leech due to the local part
of body which is affected to take out
the blood impurities
the method is quite natural and 0% of
hommies dead but not necessarily for the
leech blood impurities are said to be as
dangerous to these parasites as they are
to the patient so Ayurvedic doctors
doused their lunches in turmeric powder
to get them to expel the toxic blood you
just make the leeches to vomit because
she cannot digest a impure blood dr.
Sachin is optimistic that people's faith
in leeches will continue to hang on by
embracing this taboo treatment patients
keep an ancient cure alive and well